SANDERS’ WIN IN NEVADA WITH
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS IN HAH
MOMENT, BUT FIRST MY MOMENT.
IF YOU EVER THOUGHT PRESIDENT
DONALD J. TRUMP’S POPULARITY,
SUCCESS OR OCCUPANCY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AS YOU ATTRIBUTABLE
TO HIS BILLIONS, TAKE A LOOK AT
THE POE DENGS PRESIDENTIAL
WANNABE MICHAEL BLOOMBERG AND
THINK ABOUT.
EACH OF THEM NEW YORK CITY
STRONG-WILLED BILLIONAIRES
RUNNING TO BE PRESIDENT IN 2020.
BUT THE SIMILARITIES END THERE
AFTER BLOOMBERG’S HORRIFYING
PERFORMANCE AT THE NEVADA DEBATE
TELL THE STORY.
AFTER WATCHING THE DEBATE I AM
NOT SURE EVEN HE KNOWS WHO IS.
ONCE A DEMOCRAT, THEN A
REPUBLICAN.
THEN AN INDEPENDENT, AND NOW A
DEMOCRAT IN ORDER TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
HE’S SO WISHY WASHY AND
SPINELESS, HE DOESN’T JUST
FLIP-FLOPS, HE FLIP-FLOPS, THEN
BACK FLIPS.
AS A RESULT, HE HAS SINGLE
HANDEDLY MANAGED TO ALIENATE
JUST ABOUT EVERYONE HE MEETS IN
HIS QUIKS QUIXOTIC EFFORT TO BEC
PRESIDENT.
THERE ARE 40 SEPARATE WORK KISS
CRIPPLE NATION AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CASES HE SETTLED AT
HIS COMPANY, ALL OF THEM SEALED
BY A NON-DISCLOSURE AGREEMENT
PREVENTING THE WOMEN FROM
SPEAKING.
TO HER CREDIT, ELIZABETH WARREN
WENT UP ONE SIDE OF BLOOMBERG
AND DOWN THE OTHER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MR. MAYOR, ARE YOU WILLING TO
RELEASE ALL OF THOSE WOMEN BE
FROM THOSE NON-DISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS SO WE CAN HEAR THEIR
SIDE OF THE STORY?
>> NONE OF THEM ACCUSED ME OF
DOING ANYTHING OTHER THAN MAYBE
THEY DIDN’T LIKE A JOKE I TOLD.
AND LET ME -- THE AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN TWO PARTIES WHO WANTED
TO KEEP IT QUITE AND THAT’S UP
TO THEM.
THEY SIGNED THOSE AGREEMENTS,
AND WE’LL LIVE WITH IT.
JUDGE JEANINE: WELL, APPARENTLY
HIS HANDLERS DECIDED HE COULDN’T
LIVE WITH IT.
HIS MUZZLING THEN REFUSING TO
RELEASE WOMEN FROM THOSE
AGREEMENTS WAS NOT FAIR.
BLOOMBERG FOR YEARS HAS BATTLED
WOMEN’S ALLEGATIONS OF PROFANE
SEXIST COMMENTS AS HE RAN A
COUNTRY WITH A CULTURE OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THAT APPEARED TO BE
PERVASIVE.
ONE HIGH-PROFILE CASE FROM A
SALES WOMAN WHO ALLEGED HE TOLD
HER TO QUOTE KILL IT WHEN SHE
TOLD HIM SHE WAS PREGNANT.
THERE WAS A WITNESS TO THAT
CONVERSATION.
THAT BEHAVIOR HAS MANAGED TO TEE
OFF A LOT OF WOMEN IN AMERICA.
THEN THERE IS STOP AND FRISK.
BLOOMBERG HAS APOLOGIZED FOR
USING STOP AND FRISK AT THE TIME
HE WAS THEIR, MANAGING TO
ALIENATE ALMOST ALL OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THOSE WHO
BELIEVE IF HANDLED CORRECTLY,
STOP AND FRISK WAS AN EFFECTIVE
CRIME-FIGHTING TOOL.
BUT HE WAS SO UNPREPARED FOR
THIS QUESTION THAT IS OF
PARTICULAR INTEREST TO THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY, THAT
HE STUMBLED AND ACTED AS THOUGH
HE NEVER EXPECTED THE QUESTION.
>> WELL, IF I GO BACK AND LOOK
AT MY TIME IN OFFICE, THE ONE
THING THAT I’M REALLY WORRIED
ABOUT, HE BASED ABOUT --
EMBARRASSED ABOUT, IS HOW IT
TURNED OUT WITH STOP AND FRISK.
JUDGE JEANINE: IN THAT LANDMARK
DECISION THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT WITH JUSTICE
THURGOOD MARSHALL RULED THAT THE
4th AMENDMENT PROHIBITION ON
UNREASONABLE SEARCHES AND
SEIZURES IS NOT VIOLATED UNDER
STOP AND FRISK IF THE OFFICER
HAS A REASONABLE SUSPICION THE
PERSON IS INVOLVED IN
CRIMINALITY AND HE MAYBE ARMED.
BUT MAYOR WHAT YOU NEED TO BE
WORRIED ABOUT IS YOU BELIEVE THE
WAY TO GET GUNS OUT OF KIDS’
HANDS IS TO THROW THEM UP
AGAINST THE WALL AND FRISK THEM
AND 90 PERSON * --% OF MURDERS F
M.O.
YOU THINK YOU CAN TAKE ONE
DESCRIPTION, XEROX IT AND HAND
IT OUT TO COPS.
AND YOU THINK TALKING TO A BUNCH
OF AFRICAN-AMERICAN CLERGY AND
BUSINESS PEOPLE.
YOU SAT DOWN WITH A BUNCH OF
AFRICAN-AMERICAN CLERGY TO
FIGURE THIS OUT?
BUT THE SHAME OF THIS, THIS IS
THE ONE SIGNATURE ACCOMPLISHMENT
THAT YOU CONTINUED FROM THE RUDE
YESTERDAY * D FROM THE RUDY
GIULIANI ADMINISTRATION WHERE
LIVES WERE ACTUALLY SAVED.
AND NOW, YOU SAY IF YOU HAD TO
DO IT OVER AGAIN YOU WOULD NOT
DO STOP AND FRISK.
SAYING YOU WOULD GO BACK TO THE
2,500 VICTIMS A YEAR.
>> I CAN TEACH ANYBODY, TO BE A
FARMER.
IT’S A PROCESS.
YOU DIG A HOLE, PUT IN A SEED,
WATER IT AND UP COMES THE CORN.
300 YEARS OF THE INDUSTRIAL
SOCIETY, YOU PUT THE PIECE OF
METAL IN THE LATHE IN THE
DIRECTION OF THE AIR SO AND YOU
CAN HAVE A JOB.
JUDGE JEANINE: WHAT?
>> WHAT YOU JUST SAID IS ONE OF
THE MOST INSANELY IDIOTIC THINGS
I EVER HEARD.
AT NO POINT IN YOUR RAMBLING
INCOHERENT RESPONSE WERE YOU
EVEN CLOSE TO ANYTHING THAT
COULD BE CONSIDERED A RATIONAL
THOUGHT.
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM IS DUMBER
FOR HAVING LISTENED TO IT.
I AWARD YOU NO POINTS AND MAY
GOD HAVE MERCY ON YOUR SOUL.
JUDGE JEANINE: MAY I REMINDS
YOU, MR. MAYOR, YOU ARE RUNNING
AS A DEMOCRAT, AND YOU CANNOT
EXHIBIT OR ARTICULATE BLATANT
TRANSPHOBIA.
QUOTE IF YOUR CONVERSATION
DURING A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
IS ABOUT SOME GUY WEARING A
DRESS AND WHETHER HE, SHE OR IT
CAN GO TO THE LOCKER WOMB LOCK -
LOCKER ROOM WITH THEIR DAUGHTER
THAT’S NOT A WINNING FORMULA FOR
MOST PEOPLE.
YOU MANAGED TO TEE OFF THE
WOMEN, FARMERS,
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, LAW
ENFORCEMENT, THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY.
IS THERE ANYONE LEFT?
OH, YES.
IF YOU ARE 95 AND YOU NEED
MEDICAL CARE WE PROBABLY
SHOULDN’T HAVE TO GIVE IT TO YOU
SINCE ACCORDING TO BLOOMBERG
IT’S NOT REALLY COST EFFECTIVE.
GET IT?
AND HOW ABOUT FAMILY MEMBERS OF
THE VICTIMS OF ONE OF THE
GREATEST CRIMES IN OUR NATION’S
HISTORY.
YOU TRIED TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE
YOU WERE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
NEW YORK ON 9/11.
BY THE WAY YOU WEREN’T.
MAYOR RUDY GIULIANI WERE.
BUT YOU MADE SURE YOU BOUGHT OUR
WAY INTO A THIRD TERM EVEN
THOUGH THE CITY CH CHARTER
PROVIDED FORWARD TWO TMS.
SPEAKING OF 9/11, YOU ARE ON
TAPE TELLING THE WIDOWS OF THE
VICTIMS KILLED THAT DAY TO QUOTE
SUCK IT UP AND MOVE ON.
AND FINALLY, THEN THERE IS
ANOTHER KINDS OF SMALL CATEGORY,
GUNS.
THAT PRETTY MUCH ALIENATES
EVERYONE ELSE IN THE COUNTRY.
I HAVE HANDGUNS, LONG GUNS, MASS
DO MANY, MANY AMERICANS.
WE ARE LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS AND
WE ARE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT
SOME CRIMINAL DOES WITH HIS OR
HER GUN.
BUT YOU MR. BLOOMBERG WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING IN YOUR POWER TO TAKE
AWAY THOSE GUNS.
I HAVE NEWS FOR YOU.
IT AIN’T GOING TO HAPPEN.
I UNDERSTAND YOU ARE PLOTTING A
STRATEGY FOR A BROKERED
CONVENTION.
SEEING HOW AS YOU HAVEN’T WON
AND SINGLE DELEGATES.
YOU ARE THE BIGGEST LOSER IN THE
HIGHEST-WATCHED DEBATE IN
DEMOCRAT HISTORY.
AND YOU SPENT OVER $400 MILLION
TO GET AMERICANS TO KNOW YOU AND
YOU CAME OUT ON STAGE AND BLEW
IT ALMOST AS SOON AS YOU SHOWED
UP.
MAY I SUGGEST A NEW DEBATE TEAM
OR A PERSONALITY CHANGE.
YOU CERTAINLY CAN AFFORD IT.
THAT’S MY OPEN.